[Music]
oh [ __ ] mad flavor coming to you hold on
hold on we are do the opening as
professionals to this [ __ ] Thursday
you got no time to [ __ ] around you ready
[Applause]
come on now that's how you open up a
[ __ ] morning Paris go [ __ ]
it's a beautiful day to be alive the sun
shining right through the [ __ ] trees
I got my Roberto Clemente they shut out
from JB Cheryl direct from [ __ ]
Pittsburgh
thus the birds are chirpin I got the
best weed in [ __ ] town
and it's a [ __ ] beautiful better be
alive you're alive man think about that
you wake up tomorrow's payday all these
[ __ ] man made the lemmas in your mind
but the meanwhile there's nothing going
on but you [ __ ] it's just some reefer
you relax your breathe who gives a [ __ ]
everything about Dave no debtors prison
brothers if you own money they can suck
your dick and call you shorty Lincoln
Jail walking back my cell is mine got it
as I was working out today I got 20
hours and it's going to weave and the
Chinese [ __ ] lunch I get an egg roll
a bowl of soup or a salad a [ __ ] one
time and an entree you understand me
[ __ ] you and the horse you come up right
now it's Thursday [ __ ] June 2nd
what's your [ __ ] problem
my promise I got the world by the ball
from 53 and your mag NIF your 25 the
damage you could [ __ ] do stop your
[ __ ] crying you got the world by the
[ __ ] balls these [ __ ] immigrants
walking around and school loans and
you're like I don't know I don't know
where to get a job you have [ __ ] mutt
get up get up put some [ __ ] fake
glasses on put on Social Security got an
envelope something it's better than
sitting there [ __ ] my life you know
what suck a bag of dicks I don't [ __ ]
know but it's better than [ __ ]
clapping playing well smoke some weed
get a notebook do something
who gives a [ __ ] I'm just happy to be
[ __ ] alive I'm saying I'd have three
dollars in my pocket I got [ __ ] up
athena's aren't but guess what anything
is better than living in [ __ ] some
third-world nation eatin flies and [ __ ]
in a [ __ ] card would cup understand
me so get your [ __ ] together stop your
[ __ ] whining put on Led Zeppelin 2
and smoke a [ __ ] mole what Joey
I do it's all about I got the [ __ ]
stick
line up the paperclip for short
distances you understand me you gotta be
prepared that's the name of the game is
Thursday you wash your [ __ ] your powder
your nutsack you put a little [ __ ]
foot powder on your [ __ ] feet and you
get out there you do the best you could
do if they don't like it
I can suck your dick who gives a [ __ ]
push you to go rope I don't give a [ __ ]
ain't got time to be [ __ ] around
ain't got time to be [ __ ] around
neither do you [ __ ] smoke a bowl
put on Sabbath [ __ ] sabotage and see
what you're missing
beside dying at Victory no you get - I
got a couple meetings I have a spot
tonight The Comedy Store no podcasts no
nothing I did jail son its podcast I did
your roving podcast like the two of my
when I'm on [ __ ] podcast it out well
do is get some Sun through it throw some
kettle bells around and smoke a little
reefer
I got do it riding I gotta [ __ ] get a
[ __ ] beating from PB really it get
excited about getting a beat I don't
know I got on there these people lie to
me you know Tommy whatever the [ __ ] I
want to hear and then I just get my club
but I go you know what did I need that
[ __ ] dose of bad breath in my life
I gotta tell you people something
I like the bed early last night and I
hope swing up this morning so by its
nine o'clock whatever the [ __ ] to this
tent tonight I'm stoned dubbing easels
well they had a [ __ ] armored no
smoothie I'm gonna be a little dig bar
for breakfast and that's it Lisa there's
a way to [ __ ] Boston you [ __ ]
crime stop to so many [ __ ] random map
they had him on all fours then went to
his luggage
tsa is a [ __ ] but besides that
that's all out of the end the only thing
that's in your hands is your [ __ ]
dick your ballsack
in your heart all you could do is get up
and get up stand up for your right get
up stand up what don't give up the fight
oh [ __ ] uncle Joey listening to [ __ ]
where I get music in his head that's
when you know it's gonna be a [ __ ]
good
have I told you guys I love smoking I
love it especially when you hear these
birds chirp when you smoking leaf in
here birds it does something to you
understand me it really does you don't
know how fortunate we are to [ __ ]
wake up be alive and being this country
have no [ __ ] idea
[ __ ] Trump alien burning [ __ ] Obama [ __ ]
home it's you that has to go to the
grocery store it's you that has to
[ __ ] get up in the morning and go
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] with people don't have
to hand combat all that [ __ ] don't even
matter in a micro world don't matters
you what you're doing what you ain't
doing listen you want to worry about if
they're a [ __ ] go to China that's
your [ __ ] business weapons they gotta
do it you all you gotta do is be you and
live through everything else is
background [ __ ] music understand me
walking around I still haven't decided
on my vote you know your voters work
well guts
you're not much is gonna change dick
because you've still got a little work
and that very thing you know what at the
end of the year they take another piece
of your fate when you [ __ ] pay tax
you get your tax bill you ever look at
you like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
going on I don't even have that cuffs on
they're [ __ ] me in yes but what are
you gonna do
we were fortunate that's all I got to
tell you got service you got a problem
smoke some weed and look at the real
picture put on [ __ ] I know it's a
good day today with something Beatles
let it be Beatles right out there's a
good day for certain [ __ ] I don't
understand you the stray cats they
smoked on a bowl and listening to you
little [ __ ] Victrola with that listen
people
I got [ __ ] they're doing people to see
you know I love me I like the city with
you all [ __ ] day long smoke and
breathe from reminisce about the old
country
why are we gonna go out and [ __ ] be 20s
and get our lunchbox back if we're over
here talking [ __ ] smoking dope L know
where I don't know anybody I said it so
with that I'm gonna bow out and tell you
[ __ ] I love you
I'm stolen to the gills
understand the smoke signal for the
ellipse and that's it
I love you [ __ ] all my heart
okay spooky time he stood before Leon
what a boxer Jimmy all you [ __ ]
you know that that day oh you
[ __ ] Johnny Church have a great
[ __ ] day don't let nobody [ __ ] with
you and at the end of the day it's all
about you don't matter who [ __ ] Ben
Franklin to be President don't [ __ ] the
matter you still buy the off and bang it
out with these [ __ ] Savage I love you
stay black